while doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness was rumored to have just
about every cameo you could imagine only
a handful came to fruition captain
carter professor x captain marvel black
bolt and reed richards all appeared
briefly as members of the illuminati
before being killed by wanda maximoff
despite some of these cameos being
revealed in trailers and tv spots before
the film john krasinski and anson
mount's appearances were quite the shock
the former was especially exciting given
that the office star was fan cast as
reed richards many years ago krasinski's
cameo was probably the best of the bunch
but there was another in the film that
holds much more weight than all the
others combined in the mid-credits scene
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness a mystery character appears on
the streets of new york while stephen
strange is taking a stroll a
blonde-haired beauty with some sick
purple eyeliner appears and tells steven
that he created an incursion what
happens when two universes collide and
uses a gnarly blade to cut a portal open
to a mystery dimension the duo takes off
through the portal to parts unknown and
clear disappears as quickly as she
arrives charlize theron's appearance is
exciting enough as it's always thrilling
when a new a-lister joins the mcu out of
nowhere but the reveal that she's
playing clear is doubly exciting as this
is a major player from marvel comics
while her history is complicated the
abridged version is that clear it's a
very powerful extra-dimensional being
whose uncle is dormammu she also marries
stephen which could change the former's
trajectory entirely however stephen and
clear eventually separate after she
becomes a ruler of the dark dimension
their very twisted storyline in the
comics leaves the writers for a
potential third doctor strange film with
plenty of source material to pull from
which might reshape the mcu entirely in
2021's death of dr strange issue 1 our
beloved stephen dies at the hand of
cassilius just before his last breath
steven bequeaths a cloak of levitation
to clear she takes his name and receives
his blessing to become the sorcerer
supreme clear strange is currently
running the show in the comics in the
strange series and this very well could
mean theron takes on the mantle as
sorcerer supreme in the nia mcu future
this is a trend that's been going on
with some of our beloved infinity saga
characters so why wouldn't the
sorcerer's supreme mantle be passed on
something would have to happen to wang
for this to happen in the mcu so we'll
have to wait to see what kevin feige and
company have planned if clear taking
over is a real thing that is with sam
wilson as the new captain america kate
bishop as the new hawkeye angelina
bellova as our new black widow basically
it would make sense that they're on to
take over benedict cumberbatch's role
for now mum is a word on theron's
involvement in any future mcu films she
did cryptically tweets that the cat was
out of the bag but has yet to hint that
she might be showing up in more projects
our guess she definitely is and she
might be donning the cloak of levitation
sooner than we think check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
mcu movies are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]